all these girls are going to be jealous
now because I get to spend part of my
Valentine's Day with what I hear is you
know one of the most romantic guys at
the network joining me now Jimmy phela
Fox News contributor host of fox Across
America on Fox News Radio all right
Jimmy that's what you know that's what
you tell us at least so yep uh well I I
treat you like a queen Laura I'll take
you to White Castle all right fantastic
and look we kind of match or we at least
we accent each other all right Jimmy
um we're gonna get to the romance in a
moment but first since you're an avid
fast food connoisseur and I know you are
I have to ask if you've ever come across
well I Had A Moment Like This
welcome to Good Burger home of the Good
Burger can I take your order you're not
like other people are you
probably put us in the direction of the
little girl
[Music]
well I'm not seeping into real real life
now right former Shake Shack employee
yeah just got a 20 000 settlement
because he was misgendered by co-workers
didn't receive support from management
when he reported it Jimmy 20K because
you got the there of he or she wrong
yeah you can see this in the new court
drama 12 Angry them come on Laura this
is stupid but the idea that it was 20
grand it isn't actually a lot of money
in California you could make more than
that in one drag show for kindergarten
kids but this is insane I mean and the
only other thing I would add is 20 grand
at Shake Shack is like two extra value
meals because it's so overpriced for the
crazy liberals that he did I love The
Tick Tock videos of all these you know
just aggrieved liberals like I have my
pronouns on a pin and I'm wearing it and
I'm a barista and I'm wearing it and you
still get it wrong like how could they
break down in tears I mean it is like
they got the plague or something my
goodness all right Jimmy it is bad it is
nothing pronoun plansive than a paper
straw moving on exactly all right Jimmy
it is Valentine's Day almost over but if
you haven't gotten anything yet for
Jenny might I suggest something from the
Bronx Zoo
love me truly truly
lovely love got me hooked with your wild
ways I can't get you from my head
[Music]
nothing says love like a roach
Jimmy I I just I just want everyone in
the rest of the country to know we're
not kidding this is a real program but
the problem is supplies are limited
because all the New York roaches are
moving to Florida
they said the taxes were too high and
Adams put other roaches in their roach
motels so they're fleeing now but dude
anybody who thinks it's a good idea to
buy someone a roach for Valentine's Day
doesn't have a human partner to begin
with so this goes nowhere Jimmy don't
you love those gifts like well I made a
donation in your name I think that was a
Seinfeld episode once like like we want
to see evidence of the donation in your
name oh I I named the star after you
here's your certificate I've named a
star oh get out of town where where are
the chocolate all right Jimmy what do
you think that Biden writes on his
Valentine's Day cards what do you think
he's writing
oh if you got a Valentine from Biden
today it says happy St Patrick's Day
that's my first guess my second guess is
it probably gets a little kinky from
there you know like I never have
problems with inflation when you're
around you know something like that
Laura I'll give you I'll give you a
night to remember but I'll forget your
name like this isn't good stuff but the
truth is Biden sent Jill balloons for
Valentine's Day but NORAD shot them down
so now it's a mess and we understand
they are benign right there was no
significant payload on the balloons so
and did China launch them and have they
been observing them since the balloons
left China which they're all made in
China anyway and floated to the White
House I mean right okay now what about
Kamala what would a card from Kamala say
oh wow uh roses are red violets are blue
if you like dumb women I'm the gal for
you that's my first guess very selfish
second guesses please be my Valentine
because my husband is kissing Jill Biden
probably number two number three is I
love you more than I love a Venn diagram
which is saying something because we
know Kamala loves a Venn diagram
or out or outer space Jimmy she loves
outer space and electric buses oh my
gosh Jimmy the roach they I I would
never allow anyone to name a roach after
you okay maybe another arachnid but not
a roach Jimmy great to see you happy
Valentine's Day